it's a big day the White House is
president Trump marks 500 days in office
by touting his accomplishments the
economy is booming the North Korea
summit is back on and the president has
rebuilt the military but the dark cloud
of the special council Russia probe
continues to hang over his head
this weekend someone leaked a 20 page
letter the president's legal team wrote
back in January to Muller's lawyers it
argues that President Trump cannot
possibly commit obstruction of justice
and then he has the broad authority to
pardon himself this morning Trump
tweeted he has the right to pardon
himself but wouldn't because he's done
nothing wrong
this comes after the president's lawyer
Rudy Giuliani said in interviews the
president might have the authority to
pardon himself do you and the
president's attorneys believe the
president has the power to pardon
himself he probably not but he probably
does he has no intention of pardoning
himself but he probably doesn't say
can't I mean that is another issue
really interesting constitutional
argument can the president pardon
himself the White House is also
addressing this issue the president said
that I have an absolute right to pardon
myself why does he think that and does
he also agree with Rudy Giuliani as
lawyer that a pardon for himself would
be unthinkable and would lead to
immediate impeachment thankfully the
president hasn't done anything wrong and
wouldn't have any need for a pardon does
the president believe that he is above
the law
certainly not the president hasn't done
anything wrong
all right so 500 days Greg I think a
fair assessment whether you agree with
his policies or not he has accomplished
quite a bit it's I like to figurative as
the fifth anniversary of his first 100
days a lot of stuff has happened in 500
days but I'm not talking about the White
House I'm actually talking about your
life the key is life went on for
everybody for this 500 days and even a
Trump critic has to admit that your life
either stayed the same or it got
marginally too dramatically better
that's
pretty much the options here but but it
didn't implode because according to the
predictions by now we would have had a
civil war we would have had a nuclear
war we would have had a depression
perhaps asteroids would have hit so the
point is we have had peaceful prosperity
life went merrily on and if people just
step outside of their emotional bubble
they'll see that this is a pretty good
age to be in right now
and you and your biggest problem you
have is a president that drives you
crazy because you don't like his
personality but you have your prosperity
you have low unemployment you have a
strong economy you have no Isis you have
perhaps
North Korea actually becoming part of
the world but imagine if there was bad
news imagine if there was bad news how
the media the media is already in a
constant meltdown with good news I mean
imagine if things were actually bad I
mean it would they would be we have to
institutionalize all of them they'd be
going crazy all right so one are you are
you sick of all the winning you know I
mean he's so popular I mean stunningly
popular you know he's not popular with
the general populace but he's very
popular with Republicans and I think
that's what's keeping him afloat so Greg
says you know everything is just great
so much occur you know but I think this
is a president who worries people I
think that's why people are concerned
about him and if you look at the
accomplishment his number-one
accomplishment I saw in the White House
release was the tax cuts and of course
Republicans don't even think they can
run on tax cuts in the fall because they
just haven't proven to be that popular
the second one I guess is keep putting a
conservative Neal Gorsuch on the Supreme
Court and I would save hats off
you guys won that one but I would give
the credit to Mitch McConnell who saved
that seat from Merrick garland and then
if you look at the rest of it well even
on the tax cut the debt the deficit
continues to rise incredibly and no
progress on infrastructure which was a
key promise and no wall I could go on
but you know what I think if you want
don't it feels to me like you guys say
500 days it feels to me like wow 500
years well it looks like
boss if and when a human has to take the
one that really gets me is the
immigration stuff but we'll talk about
it later but immigration and kids that I
understand and we will get to that
Kimberly the Martin situation yeah
legally that might have been some
gamesmanship it looks like he got set up
Rudy Guiliani on the question didn't
really know what to say there how do you
see the whole pardon thing playing out
today yeah I think you're right because
you look at the nuance they're ready to
kind of said well proposes an
interesting constitutional you know
question can the president pardon
himself I mean well then the president
followed up with the tweed thing in fact
that he can so perhaps he then spoke to
someone says I you're safe to go ahead
you know and tweet that who knows but
nevertheless you don't even want to get
to that point right here you don't want
to even suggest that that would even be
necessary the president would have to do
that you would just say okay well I've
done nothing wrong
so actually don't even have to get to
the question of whether or not I can
pardon myself because there will be
nothing on the merits to suggest any
kind of criminality on my part that's a
kind of a messaging that I would stick
with and stick with that position
because if that's in fact what he
believes and he knows the facts and what
transpired better than anybody you know
in terms of what's gone on and then of
course being a prized by his counsel of
what's gone on that's kind of AI
probably the way to stick with it
because as he saw the press corps then
was saying does the president think that
he's above the law what a question yeah
that was you want to also figure it at
all switch the discussion like dana says
give them the points to kind of talk
about and drive the messaging talk about
the economy sort of the Trump golden
aids of the economy in terms of job
numbers and things like that and not be
discussing the whole criminality yeah to
bring up the P word unprompted on a day
where I think yes Dana and the Lewinsky
thing that's a different he drove yes
thank you Greg he drove that out of the
news cycle and now everyone's talking
about pardon well the White House brings
us on themselves a little bit late so
the president's tweets are driving the
news cycle so when he's tweeting about
it you can bet that that's what people
going to talk about so if you only want
people to talk about all of these good
things
tweet only about those good things and
that would be helpful I do think it's
interesting that you know you had this
Republican Congress for two years five
months from tomorrow is the midterms and
right after that immediately the day
after you start the 2020 election and I
think what is so interesting is a good
Democrat well here we go again Democrats
are so befuddled at this point because
what do you do do you have as Greg was
pointing out think of all these good
news things if those of all of these
good news points had happened during the
Obama administration they would have
touted them too and it could be that the
Democrats are going to have to just use
this time to step back and sit if your
timing politics is timing so regroup you
got a rig you know fill out those ranks
out in the States because that was all
depleted during the Obama administration
and figure out a way to try to at least
get through the midterms if they could
turn that flip the house will see I
think is really I guess it's 50/50 at
this point and the Republicans looking
so much stronger so the Democrats have
spent 500 days not figuring out how they
lost in 2016 which means that they are
behind in figuring that out because 2020
is gonna be here like before you know it
and I don't see how the roaring economy
changes I don't see how the foreign
policy position changes in 2008 unless
there's some catastrophic event which
hopefully there is not but that we are
better positioned to deal with and in
the meantime parties change they evolve
obviously this is what's happening with
the Republican Party but that the
Republican Party has gone done that that
I think is pretty much over
and so the Democrats are the ones now
that are in a position of figuring out
who are we what are we going to be yeah
they might have to reinvent themselves
let's hope so you know the Democrats
have an advantage in that they are out
of power and when we were out of power
you have all the time in the world to
get back into power that's what you're
supposed to do that's why you know you
know Carter was a reaction to Nixon
Reagan was a reaction to Carter but but
yeah everything's a reaction to somebody
else but the problem is they've spent
the last two years in a tantrum they
blown all this time they I don't even
think they they've found anyone what
would
remise yeah what would be the reaction
to Donald Trump
could you imagine with the opposite no
but that's a very good point I said cuz
no it's an employment no but I'm saying
it'll be somebody incredibly left-wing
because you always see the pendulum
shift and if you know if if they get it
they might try to like he he's undoing
everything Obama did the next one is
gonna try to and do everything Trump it
it'll the opposite of Trump probably is
a female Hispanic very polite librarian
the thing is I think that you're right
the pendulum swings but remember if a
Democrat was doing what Trump is doing
let's say you know that this weekend as
part of this business about I can he can
pardon himself it came out that in that
letter it was acknowledged that in fact
he had dictated this letter about Donald
Trump juniors meeting at Trump Tower
with this Russian lawyer and we had
heard from the Trump officials that that
wasn't true repeatedly from Sarah
Huckabee Sanders basic low and others so
now comes out that we were lied to and I
just think if Obama did something like
that Jesse I think you would be standing
on this table brother you would be
screaming about oh but that lie has is
not even close to Benghazi nothing
anyway he lied about that or not dead
ambassador oh stop so my sense is that
we have here a situation where the
Republican Party has consolidate around
Trump or Trump has made the Republican
party into the Trump party that's the
big change in the first 500 days well
you know you say they say the democratic
party became the Obama party I don't
think that's leadership they were as you
said decimated on the state and locals
real quick in terms of the you know
accomplishments to the first 500 days
there are get considerable especially as
it relates to the economy and you saw
people really having a difficult time
going against President Bill Clinton
when the economy and the numbers were
good so what is the antithesis of that
to undo the economic numbers and to you
don't want to do jobs raise unemployment
me yes what right but this is the point
hey Isis you know come back
to bring something forward I don't think
it's the opposite I think it's the kind
of the polar political well so then not
to come up here looks like trumping you
know why white guy the tax cuts
benefited the rich Bernie Sanders would
say tax cuts that benefit working-class
people not the rich in California your
education for you I think you're looking
at somebody like a Carla Harris or
strong candidate like that I mean a
woman yes absolutely but also what in
terms of what she's wrong and somebody
who isn't you know the same candidate
ran before run through the you know the
rinse cycle one more time
Ron is still feeling the Bern after 500
days